[ZH] 讀教大學社群心理學榮譽教授
[ZH] Pofasaki Sasao
[ZH] 來為我們帶來下午的講題
[ZH] 他要談的是自閉症、神經多樣性、社群歸屬感、社群心理學的一個視角
[ZH] 那接下來我們就請Pofasaki Sasao
[ZH] 為我們做一個詳細的說明跟分享
[ZH] 那一樣大家有認為的問題
[ZH] 可以在QR Code表單裡面提出來
[ZH] 那是不是讓我們掌聲歡迎
[EN]  Okay, good afternoon, I want to thank all the organizers and the interpreter for today.
[EN]  We had wonderful morning sessions we really enjoyed, although my understanding of Chinese
[EN]  is very limited, but I really appreciated all the slides and all the talks and a little
[EN]  But anyway, for your information, I'm a terrible nightmare for the interpreters, especially when I talk in a situation where people don't understand me.
[EN]  But it's because I tend to digress, and I put in jokes, and then I just go my own way.
[EN]  But anyway, I have this script, which is nice, so I try to be very faithful to the script that I have today.
[EN]  Now, I come to this topic as a community psychologist, rather than as a physical physician or medical professional.
[EN]  So my purpose here today is not to replace clinical knowledge or intervention, but rather I'd like to add another lens.
[EN]  That lens asks us to look not only at the autistic person, but also at the relationships.
[EN]  settings institutions communities and social expectations surrounding that person so my central
[EN]  question today is a very very simple one what changes when we understand autism not only within
[EN*]  the person but also within the ecology in which the person lives ecology uh it's a bit of a
[EN*]  It's not a technical term, but it refers to environment, social environment, natural environment, or the surrounding around that person.
[ZH] 那我今天來跟大家分享的是以一位社群心理學家的身份
[ZH] 而不是一位醫生或是臨床治療師
[ZH] 那我今天來這邊演講的故地也不是要去取代臨床的知識或是介入
[ZH] 或是介入
[ZH] 而是我想要補充另外一個視角的觀點
[ZH] 那我們今天這個視角的觀點
[ZH] 並不是隻把助力放在抑制者的本身身上
[ZH] 而是也要聚焦在它
[ZH] 圍繞在它的關係、環境、機構、社群
[ZH] 還有社會的期待值身上
[ZH] 那我們今天這邊有一個核心的問題
[ZH] 其實很簡單
[ZH] 當我們試著去用生態系統來瞭解這位自閉症患者的時候,我們會有什麼樣的改變?
[ZH] 那我這邊講的Ecology,生態系統,其實它是一個可以是很廣泛的詞,包含圍繞著這位自閉症者的社會、自然、環境以及所有的一切。
[EN*]  First, I want to widen the lens. The lens you and I have. Diagnosis and individual interventions are important, but they are only part of the picture.
[EN*]  You also need to consider relationships, schools, workplaces, families, communities, systems, and culture.
[EN]  Second, I want to learn from lived experience, including recent work from Japan and the perspectives of autistic people themselves.
[EN]  And the third, I want to translate that understanding into practice.
[EN]  Rather than assuming that adaptation has always come from the autistic person, what happens if it asks how the person and the environment can adapt together?
[EN]  Ultimately I want to move from a discussion with support towards the discussion of participation, belonging and mattering.
[ZH] 對於參與、依靈、依靈、依靈、依靈。
[ZH] 讓我開始為一個人的故事,
[ZH] 這裡表明為何一單的解釋常不足夠。
[ZH] 以及社群體系還有文化脈絡
[ZH] 那第二個我想要達到的目標是
[ZH] 汲取生活經驗
[ZH] 那包含了最近整個日本近期的
[ZH] 這個實踐成果
[ZH] 臨床專業指示
[ZH] 那第三個的話
[ZH] 我想要就是超越
[ZH] 就是這樣理解轉換為實踐的行動
[ZH] 我希望不只是這個適應
[ZH] 這件事情只是從自閉症者去出發
[ZH] 而是說我們整個環境
[ZH] 與這個人怎麼樣可以去互相,雙向去適應
[ZH] 那最後呢,我希望就是我們不只是談要如何單向的給予自閉政者支援
[ZH] 而是我們可以把討論擴及到怎麼樣更讓這個人有參與感、歸屬感以及發揮價值感
[ZH] 那我等一下會跟大家分享一個人的故事
[ZH] 那他是很難用直直片語去解釋的
[ZH] 一些人可能會有聽到的 Jason Rd
[ZH] 他變成了一位教授的教授的教授在 Cambridge
[EN]  He had been diagnosed with autism in childhood. Earlier this year, he resigned
[EN]  amid allegations concerning his academic work and intense public scrutiny shortly afterward
[EN]  he was found dead at the age of 41 which was just last month as the slides indicates
[EN]  the cause was unknown established in the information on which this slide is based
[EN]  i want to be very careful here though i am not presenting jason already as a clinical case and
[EN]  And I'm not suggesting that autism or any single event explains what happened.
[EN]  Quite the opposite.
[EN]  His life raises a question.
[EN]  Where do we look when we try to understand a human life?
[ZH] 人生,病情,社會,社會,或是文化。
[ZH] 答案是,我們在時間上都會發展。
[ZH] 那他是建曹大學史上最年輕的黑人教授
[ZH] 那他在小時候被診斷出有自閉症
[ZH] 那今年稍早呢就是他辭職了
[ZH] 因為就是有人質疑他的學術方面的一些成就
[ZH] 並不是他真正那麼值得
[ZH] 然後他也遭遇了就是大眾嚴厲的檢視
[ZH] 然後這件風波發生不久以後呢
[ZH] 他於41歲的時候就被發現身亡
[ZH] 那死因是尚未證實是什麼原因
[ZH] 那我這邊要很謹慎的說
[ZH] 就是我並不是把Jason Arden
[ZH] 在這邊當作一個臨床案例
[ZH] 然後我也不是想要用自閉症來解釋他的死因
[ZH] 那恰恰好相反我提到他是因為
[ZH] 我覺得他的人生其實是一個很好的叩問
[ZH] 就是當我們試著要去理解一個人的一生的時候
[ZH] 我們要該怎麼樣去看
[ZH] 是要看這個人還是看他的診斷結果
[ZH] 看人際關係,看體制制度,還是要看文化環境,那我覺得我的答案是,其實這些所有的因素都是互相交替的。
[EN]  an important distinction between what we know and what we sometimes assume we know that the
[EN]  autism is real and hello genius we know that individual needs matter we know that professional
[EN]  expertise is valuable and we know that that adaptation can sometimes be very helpful
[EN]  but none of those facts means that the diagnosis explains the whole person
[EN*]  And that every difficulty lies inside the individual, without functioning will look the same across every setting.
[EN*]  And perhaps most importantly, looking successful does not necessarily mean doing well.
[EN*]  So if the individual alone is not enough, then where else should we look?
[ZH] 以及適應或許是會很有幫助的
[ZH] 但是呢以上這些事實都不能夠意味著
[ZH] 就是診斷可以解釋這個人的一生
[ZH] 然後每一個這個人遇見的困難
[ZH] 在每一個這個環境當中
[ZH] 也都會有不一樣的這個運作和表現
[ZH] 然後也許最重要的是就是
[ZH] 有一個人也許他看似是很成功的
[ZH] 但是並表示他其實現在過得很好
[ZH] 那所以一個診斷的結果會告訴我們一些重要的事實
[ZH] 但是他沒有辦法告訴我們每一件事情關於這個人
[ZH] 所以如果只看這一個人是不足夠的話
[ZH] 那我們應該還要看向何方呢
[ZH]  Now community psychology begins with a very simple principle
[ZH] 而是,人們的經濟活動,人們的經濟活動, 人們的經濟活動, 人們的體驗, 人們的經濟活動, 人們的經濟活動, 人們的經濟活動, 人們的經濟活動, 人們的經濟活動, 人們的經濟活動, 人們的經濟活動, 人們的經濟活動, 人們的經濟活動。
[EN]  Home, classroom, clinic, workplace, and community.
[EN]  And there are relationships within each of these.
[EN]  And there is community life, friendship, social networks, recreation, neighborhoods, and faith communities.
[EN]  And the crucial point here is that the same person may function very differently in different environments.
[EN]  And when functioning changes substantially from one setting to another, that difference itself is useful information.
[ZH] 理學有一個很重要但是很基本的原則
[ZH] 就是人都是在不同的環境下
[ZH] 不同環境還有脈絡下面運作的
[ZH] 那這個人他可能有不同的能力需求
[ZH] 健康還有感知經驗
[ZH] 以及就是發展的特色
[ZH] 但是這個人呢
[ZH] 他在特定的環境當中
[ZH] 比如說是居家教室診所工作場域
[ZH] 或是社群裡面他會有不同的表現
[ZH] 那他也有不同發展出不同的關係
[ZH] 比如說還有不同的家庭關係,同儕關係,與老師的關係,還有與臨床工作者的關係
[ZH] 以及就是我們每個人生活中都有不同的系統,還有文化期待價值
[ZH] 比如說是政策或是一些社會的規範
[ZH] 那社群中間也會有不同的生命關係
[ZH] 比如說有友情,還有社工之間的關係,還有娛樂,還有鄰里的關係
[EN*]  The important thing is that a different person is a different person,
[EN*]  but in a different environment, he will have different performance.
[EN*]  So when we bring this person to the other environment,
[EN*]  So what specifically does community psychology contribute?
[EN*]  I would like to summarize this field of community psychology through four ideas.
[EN]  The first is ecology.
[EN]  I warned you that we call it as environmental surroundings around the individual or communities.
[EN]  Where and with whom does the difficulty occur?
[EN]  And the second principle is prevention.
[EN]  What secondary problems might we prevent before they become crisis?
[EN]  And the third is empowerment.
[EN]  Whose goals and whose knowledge count?
[EN]  And the fourth is participation and system change.
[EN]  What can change around the person?
[EN]  So our unique concern is not only the individual,
[EN]  it is also the ecology surrounding the individual.
[EN]  Now this changes the question we ask.
[EN]  Instead of asking only what's wrong,
[ZH] 所以社群心理學這個領域它是有哪些的特色和貢獻的
[ZH] 那我想要從四個方面來解釋
[ZH] 第一個的話社群心理學關注生態學
[ZH] 就是我們想要就是去觀察這個人遇到的困難是發生在哪裡
[ZH] 以及它涉及了哪些人
[ZH] 那第二個的話是預防
[ZH] 我們可以預防哪一些問題
[ZH] 在他們變成一個危機之前
[ZH] 如何做預防
[ZH] 第三個是父權
[ZH] 就是說誰的目標還有誰的知識
[ZH] 才是有話語權
[ZH] 才是真的算數的
[ZH] 那第四個是我們要如何參與系統變革
[ZH] 就是這個人身上
[ZH] 迴繞他附近的這些生態系統環境
[ZH] 我們可以怎麼樣去改變
[ZH] 所以我們的關係
[ZH] 我們的關係不只是放在這個人身上
[EN*]  We need to change the system.
[EN*]  So if you notice, I haven't talked to these two wonderful speakers from the US, but we realized yesterday that they and I complimented each other.
[EN]  So if you can kind of keep that in mind, then I won't go on.
[EN]  Now, let's consider what does this mean for autism.
[EN]  Consider a very simple example.
[EN]  A 14-year-old autistic student begins to refuse in schools.
[EN]  If you look at only an individual, we may find sensory sensitivity, anxiety, or difficulty with sudden change.
[EN]  These may be very real, and clinical intervention may be very helpful.
[EN]  But if you widen the lens, remember our first call here is to widen the lens.
[EN]  We may also discover bullying, misunderstanding with teachers, family conflict around attendance,
[EN]  a noisy classroom, unpredictable schedules, implicit social rules, or rigid school attendance policy.
[EN]  And then a range of interventions expands.
[EN]  Perhaps a student needs coping strategies of anxiety treatment.
[EN]  But perhaps a teacher needs consultation.
[EN]  Perhaps a classroom needs a quiet space.
[EN]  Perhaps instructions need to become more explicit.
[EN]  And perhaps the school policy itself needs greater flexibility.
[EN]  So both a student and environmental ecology matter.
[EN]  Community psychology often describes this as a person environment fit.
[EN*]  So with that ecological kind of framework in mind, I now want to return directly to autism itself.
[EN*]  Whitening the lens does not mean weakening diagnosis, it means asking what diagnosis can or cannot help us.
[EN*]  So here I'll give you a example.
[EN*]  If we have a 14-year-old child, he has a problem with a problem.
[EN*]  We don't only see this child's body.
[EN*]  We may see that he's a敏感, a lot of anxiety, or he's faced with a bad change.
[ZH] 身邊會出現被同儕霸凌的狀況
[ZH] 跟老師溝通出現了誤解
[ZH] 那還有家庭衝突
[ZH] 或是說他受不了
[ZH] 就是一個很吵雜的教室環境
[ZH] 或是一個充滿變動的日程表
[ZH] 還有就是可能不是很清楚的一些社會規範
[ZH] 或是一個就是很固定的一個學校出勤的政策
[ZH] 那如果我們把這個視角放大的話
[ZH] 我們就會發現
[ZH] 那我們的介入方式其實也可以跟著擴張
[ZH] 也許這個學生本身
[ZH] 他需要一些因應的策略來支援他的溝通
[ZH] 阻止他的焦慮
[ZH] 但是呢
[ZH] 如果把視角放大的話
[ZH] 也許他的教室也可以做出一些調整
[ZH] 比如說這個教室需要變得安靜一些
[ZH] 或是說就是也許給他的教導去
[ZH] 或是指令需要更清楚
[ZH] 或是說學校的一些政策是可以稍微再做一些彈性調整的
[ZH] 所以學生本人還有他身處的這個環境都非常的重要
[ZH] 社群心理學呢會把這個關係稱之為人和環境的適配性
[ZH] 那有了這樣的環境架構的話
[ZH] 我現在等一下要繼續回去討論自閉症
[ZH] 但是呢我們把視角放大不代表就是要把整段站的這個地位去弱化掉
[ZH] 其實他反而是在告訴我們診斷可以和不能告訴我們什麼事情
[EN]  Autistic people differ in communication, cognition, sensory experience, adaptive functioning, and a lot of support needed.
[EN]  A useful example comes from Saito and Kone's population study in Hirosaki, Japan.
[EN]  Hirosaki is the northern part of Japan.
[EN]  And among the 87 children identified with ASD, only about 11.5 percent had ASD without
[EN]  any other assessed neurodevelopmental condition.
[EN]  Most also had ADHD, developmental coordination disorder, intellectual disability, borderline
[EN]  intellectual functioning, or some combinations thereof.
[EN]  So even when two children have the same autism diagnosis, their developmental profiles may be quite different.
[ZH] 如果有疾病的疾病,他們的疾病不介意,也不一定的全生命。
[ZH] 所以自閉症在臨床上是一個有意義的診斷
[ZH] 但是這個診斷並不能就是適用於描述每一個人
[ZH] 那自閉症患者他們在就是不同的溝通認知
[ZH] 還有感知經驗適應功能
[ZH] 以及就是不同程度的支援下都是不同的
[ZH] 那這邊想要引用就是日本紅前市
[ZH] 就是五歲幼童流行病選就報告指出
[ZH] 就是在87個有診斷出ASD的孩子裡面
[ZH] 只有11.5%的兒童沒有其他神經發育的障礙
[ZH] 也就是說其實大部分診斷出ASD的兒童
[ZH] 他們至少都合併於一種其他的疾病
[ZH] 比如說是智力上面的障礙
[ZH] 或是有一些就是其他的疾病
[ZH] 那所以雖然假設我們今天有兩個孩子
[ZH] 他們都有診斷出自閉症
[ZH] 但是他們的發展輪廓會是很不一樣的
[ZH] 那所以這些診斷他們也代表了非常不一樣的這個模式
[ZH] 所以可以大概形容一個人的這個發展輪廓
[ZH] 並不代表可以適用於其他人
[ZH] 那同時這個發展輪廓也不能表達
[ZH] 也不能代表了他完整的一生
[EN]  Now there is another interesting complication here, that word autism serves several purposes.
[EN]  It is a diagnosis, it can determine eligibility for support, it is a scientific category used
[EN]  in the research, for some people it is also a part of social identity and community membership.
[EN]  So, Alex Zambrovsky and her colleagues asked an important question, who gets to define autism
[EN]  and for what purpose?
[EN]  The answer may differ depending on whether we are diagnosing, providing services, doing
[EN]  research, or discussing identity.
[EN]  The point here is not that one definition is necessarily correct and others are wrong.
[EN]  The point is that the same word can serve several different functions.
[ZH] 意義或是目的在
[ZH] 那自閉這兩字他可以是一個診斷
[ZH] 那他也可以是用來尋求協助的一個權利
[ZH] 那他也可以是一個科學上面的分類
[ZH] 那對於有些人來說
[ZH] 他可以是社會上的一個身份
[ZH] 或是他會是一個社群的歸屬感
[ZH] 所以Alexandrovsky醫師
[ZH] 他這個研究者
[ZH] 他就問了一個很重要的問題
[ZH] 就是是誰有權利來定義自閉症
[ZH] 然後呢為什麼要來定義它
[ZH] 那這個答案呢可能會有所不同
[ZH] 就是根據就是我們是要再做診斷呢
[ZH] 還是要提供服務還是要做學術研究
[ZH] 還是要再討論社會上面的這個身份
[ZH] 那每一個定義其實都是不一樣的
[ZH] 那沒有辦法說誰對或誰錯
[ZH] 那重點是同樣一個字眼
[EN*]  Neurodiversity does not have to mean no treatment.
[EN*]  Clinical care can reduce suffering, address co-occurring conditions, support communication, and function.
[EN*]  Neurodiversity perspective reminds us to respect neurological differences, protect dignity and agency, and avoid unnecessary normalization.
[EN]  Community psychology adds attention to the person environment fit, the person environment fit that I was talking about.
[EN]  participation, belonging, and prevention of secondary harm.
[EN]  Now these perspectives do not need to compete.
[EN]  They can complement one another.
[EN]  The phrase that I'll be using just a little bit later
[ZH] 複製作的避免運動,這是一個很大的詞。
[ZH] 避免運動並不必須要從一個人向環境。
[ZH] 今天的研究會主題是神經多樣性。
[ZH] 當我們談到神經多樣性的話,其實有一個很重要的一題我想要強調,
[ZH] 神經多樣性不代表完全不需要治療介入
[ZH] 那比如說臨床的照護就可以幫助這個當事人減輕痛苦
[ZH] 支援他溝通還有日常適應功能
[ZH] 還有神經多樣性這個觀念本身就在提醒我們說
[ZH] 我們對於神經可能發展和結構很不一樣的人應該給予尊重
[ZH] 這樣就可以確保他人的尊嚴還有自主權
[ZH] 然後也可以避免不必要的正常化
[ZH] 那社群心理學呢
[ZH] 還另外再增加了一些關注的焦點
[ZH] 比如說人與環境的適配性
[ZH] 還有改變個人的時候也同時改變環境
[ZH] 那這些觀點並不是互相排斥的
[ZH] 他們其實是互相支援補充的
[ZH] 那我等一下會講到一個詞
[ZH] 就是雙向調適
[ZH] 就是其實適應這件事情並不是單向的
[ZH] 並不是這個人去適應他的環境
[ZH] 其實環境也可以反過來適應這個人
[ZH] 然後我們需要認識這些認識
[EN]  What is expected timing of conversation?
[EN]  How much emotional expression is considered appropriate?
[EN]  How much independence is expected?
[EN]  How much conformity to group routines?
[EN]  These norms matter because differences
[EN]  are not simply observed, they are interpretive.
[EN]  Behavior may be seen as rude, immature,
[EN]  uncooperative, unusual, or disordered,
[EN]  depending on the city and the social expectations operating there.
[EN]  And then another question appears, is a combination possible, or is a person expected to hide the difference?
[EN]  Culture does not create autism, but social norms can influence whether a neurological difference becomes a barrier.
[EN]  Now, so far I've been talking about diagnosis, context, and social norms.
[EN]  I now want to shift toward the lived experience, especially some recent work from Japan.
[ZH] 尤其是日本的一些最近的工作。
[ZH] 是正常和適當的
[ZH] 然後還有多少的獨立和相互依賴是恰當的
[ZH] 怎麼樣才叫做遵守團體規範
[ZH] 其實這些所謂的社會規範
[ZH] 他們都是每個人解讀的方式不一樣
[ZH] 所以在一個環境中有一個行為
[ZH] 可能會被視為是粗乳不成熟
[ZH] 非常不禮貌的
[ZH] 但是來到另外一個環境當中
[ZH] 也許會有不一樣的社會期待值
[ZH] 所以這邊就領明到另外一個問題
[ZH] 就是我們是否可以做出調整
[ZH] 還是說我們會要求當事人要去隱藏這個與他人不一樣的地方
[ZH] 文化本身並不會創造出自閉
[ZH] 但是社會規範強加在別人身上的話
[EN*]  It is possible to make the same change in the world.
[EN*]  So I will turn to the conversation about the experience of the life of the world.
[EN*]  I will use some of the research in the recent research.
[EN*]  Now, Dr. Harada and his colleagues interviewed seven late-diagnosed autistic adults in Japan.
[EN]  Now, several themes emerged out of their discussions or interviews.
[EN]  Participants described feeling different, sometimes for many years, without necessarily understanding why.
[EN]  why. They describe misunderstanding, bullying, stigma, and social difficulty. Diagnosis sometimes
[EN]  brought relief because it offers an explanation. But diagnosis could also bring uncertainty
[ZH] 不一定的感受和混亂感受。重要的是,所要的參與者並非只是有更好的社交技術,他們也想認識、認識、信心和信心。這意味著,所要的人的需要,並非從診斥者的診斥者不一定會顯示。
[ZH] 那參與面談的這些自閉診者
[ZH] 他們描述他們的感受
[ZH] 他說他小時候就感覺到自己是從小跟人家不一樣
[ZH] 但是他始終都不知道原因
[ZH] 那他們也遭遇了就是長期被誤解啊
[ZH] 霸凌啊汙名化還有人際誤解等等
[ZH] 那就是當他們獲得診斷以後
[ZH] 他們會覺得恍然大悟釋懷的感覺
[ZH] 但同時也覺得很複雜
[ZH] 就是情感上面覺得好像
[ZH] 這個診斷也帶來了一些不確定感
[ZH] 那更重要的是
[ZH] 這些參與訪談的自閉症者
[ZH] 他們希望的其實不只是進步的社交技能
[ZH] 他們也渴望被接納、被認可
[ZH] 還有以及歸屬感
[ZH] 所以這就告訴我們
[ZH] 就是人們的需求
[ZH] 其實並不總是能從診斷結果看出
[ZH] 這事實際上和冒險。從外面,我們會看到了什麼效果的進展。
[EN]  Appropriate social behavior, eye contact, school attendance, good job performance,
[EN]  or someone who seems to be coping well.
[EN]  Now, but what may remain invisible?
[EN]  Exhaustion, anxiety, constant self-monitoring, fear of rejection.
[EN]  So perhaps the important question is not simply can this person adapt, but is this adaptation sustainable, and what is it causing the person?
[ZH] 所以可能一個重要問題是不只是可以這個人應用,但是這個人應用的應用,是否能應用,是否能應用,是否能應用,是否能應用?
[ZH] 那這個問題是醫生的,是醫生的,是醫生的。
[ZH] 那這個就引導到我接下來要談的問狀和演示的議題
[ZH] 就是我們可能從一個人的外在觀察
[ZH] 我們會覺得這個人看起來好像適應的很好啊
[ZH] 過得很成功
[ZH] 他可能展現出很恰當的社會行為
[ZH] 眼神接觸
[ZH] 也有正常出席學校
[ZH] 工作上有好的表現
[ZH] 看起來是適應的很好
[ZH] 但是呢
[ZH] 我們也有可能看不到是
[ZH] 他在內心深處他是有焦慮感
[ZH] 精疲力盡失去自己的真實身份感
[ZH] 以及長期的一個身心浩劫的狀態
[ZH] 所以我們其實不應該只是問說
[ZH] 這個人有沒有辦法適應社會
[ZH] 而是我們要去問說
[ZH] 如果真的強迫他去適應的話
[ZH] 這個適應有辦法長久維持下去嗎
[EN*]  So the access to the reason for communication difficulty is an opening.
[EN*]  Traditional model tends to say, Autistic person, communication deficit link.
[EN]  A relational model is more complicated.
[EN]  Communication happens between an Autistic person and another person
[EN]  with social norms that influence whose style is treated as standard.
[EN]  The difficulty may arise not only from the characteristics of one individual, but also
[EN]  from the interaction between different communication styles.
[EN]  If communication is relational, perhaps an understanding of communication difficulty
[ZH] 人們自己也必須參與進行製作協定的解釋
[ZH] 這帶我來的特別興奮的參與執行行程式
[ZH] 在日本製作在日本製作
[ZH] 名叫東京大學的Kumagaya教授
[ZH] 他本身也是一位生障者
[ZH] 他就邀請大家一起重新思考
[ZH] 溝通障礙是發生在哪裡
[ZH] 那傳統上面的觀景會說就是一個自閉症患者跟他一定是出現溝通上的缺陷
[ZH] 那我們去解讀這個關係的時候其實是很複雜的
[ZH] 因為溝通他為什麼會發生
[ZH] 他是發生在兩個人之間的談話
[ZH] 那當一個自閉症者和另外一個人在一個社會規範之下
[ZH] 那就是通常會以就是另外一個人當作是一個標準
[ZH] 所以當一個自閉症者和另外一個
[ZH] 就是所謂正常人出現了不同的溝通模式的時候
[ZH] 就有可能會出現溝通障礙
[ZH] 那我們要怎麼樣去讓自閉症者
[ZH] 能夠更好的參與產出這個理解的過程呢
[ZH] 那這就帶領到我下一個要講的主題
[ZH] 日本現在有一個研究方法,叫做當事者研究
[ZH] Tōjisha Kenkyu,日本人的英文,是難以完全翻譯
[ZH] Tōjisha 名為人的疑問和影響
[ZH] Kenkyu 名為研究、研究、研究
[ZH] 中文字幕提供
[EN]  started at Urakawa Bethel House in Hokkaido, Northern Ireland, around 2001,
[EN]  among people living with psychiatric difficulties,
[EN]  and has since then been used in other contexts,
[EN]  including autism and neurodiversity.
[EN]  The process is peer-led and collaborative.
[EN]  People investigate their own difficulties,
[EN]  identify recurring patterns, develop a language
[EN]  for what they're experiencing, and explore ways
[EN]  of coping or living with those difficulties.
[EN]  Now for me, these principles, several principles
[EN]  are special and important.
[EN]  A person becomes the producer of knowledge, understanding comes before normalisation, knowledge is co-produced, and change can potentially occur on both sides, the person and environment.
[EN]  So instead of immediately asking what deficit does this person have, Tojisha can be asked how does this difficulty actually happen?
[ZH] 那一開始是患有精神疾病的這個居民裡面進行的
[ZH] 但是後來慢慢被應用在就是研究其他的一些症狀
[ZH] 比如說是自閉症以及神經多樣性
[ZH] 那這是一個由同儕主導共同協作的實踐歷程
[ZH] 那他會邀請面臨困境的當事人
[ZH] 親自去探究自身的生活經驗
[ZH] 那辨識反覆出現的行為模式
[ZH] 發展出共同的描述語言
[ZH] 來摸索因應與困難怎麼樣去共存下去的一個方法
[ZH] 所以在當事者研究裡面有幾個原則很重要
[ZH] 首先是這個當事人他就成為知識的生產者
[ZH] 他不再是一個單純被觀察的物件
[ZH] 然後關於這個症狀的知識
[ZH] 是由這個當事人跟其他人一起共同產出的
[ZH] 然後這些改變他會發生在雙項中
[ZH] 就是除了當事人要改變,環境應該也要跟著改變
[ZH] 所以我們問的問題就不再只是說
[ZH] 這個人有什麼缺陷,他有什麼樣不適應的地方
[ZH] 當事者研究的問法會是什麼樣的困難實際的發生呢
[ZH] So let me give you a hypothetical
[EN]  now let me give you a hypothetical example here imagine a 15 year old autistic student who says
[EN]  i suddenly cannot speak during group discussion it's a familiar situation we often find that
[EN]  now one of the potential might be poor social skills but position can't use slows the process
[EN]  down first perhaps that what happens to me the student says my mind goes blank
[EN]  I can't tell when to speak.
[EN]  Then what does it happen?
[EN]  Perhaps when several people are talking,
[EN]  topics change quickly and term taking is unclear.
[EN]  And then what patterns do we notice?
[EN]  The student is processing multiple voices,
[EN]  monitoring several faces,
[EN]  deciding when it is safe to enter the conversation
[EN]  and worrying about interacting.
[EN]  Now the explanation begins to change, if a student does have things to say, the difficulty
[EN]  may be getting into this particular kind of conversation, and then what helps?
[EN]  Those are changes, questions in advance, explicit turn taking, small groups, smaller groups
[EN]  for written response options.
[EN]  So understanding changes the intervention target.
[EN]  We move from poor social skills to what person environment fit is producing this difficulty.
[ZH] 他說,今天在課堂上的小組討論中,我們不完無法發言
[ZH] 那我們可能一般的解讀會是,這個自閉症的孩子他就是社交技巧不如人
[ZH] 但是當事者研究會緩下來,重新檢視一下這個過程
[ZH] 首先當事者研究會去檢視說,問這個孩子,請他要說說我怎麼了
[ZH] 然後他就回答說我的腦袋不染片空白
[ZH] 我不知道什麼時候該說話
[ZH] 然後接下來當事者研究會去探究說
[ZH] 這個情況是什麼時候會發生的
[ZH] 那孩子可能會說當很多人同時在講話
[ZH] 或是話題快速切換的時候
[ZH] 或是發言順序不清楚誰該講話的時候
[ZH] 這種事情特別容易發生在我身上
[ZH] 那接下來當事者研究會問說
[ZH] 你就會問說那哪些模式是需要留意的
[ZH] 那可能這個學生他就是會
[ZH] 當他同時要處理很多的聲音面孔
[ZH] 或是常常就是他會擔心要打斷別人
[ZH] 那這個時候呢
[ZH] 這個學生他
[ZH] 這個時候當事者研究就會問說
[ZH] 那我們可以做出什麼樣的方法來幫助你
[ZH] 比如說我們就可以提前提問
[ZH] 然後呢,該誰發言的時候可以把它訂得更明確一點
[ZH] 以及就是可以去讓他用書面回答這個選項
[ZH] 所以當這個理解不一樣的時候
[ZH] 我們的介入方式和目標也會不一樣
[ZH] 我們就不會只是很簡單的去診斷這個孩子
[ZH] 他就是社交技巧不足
[ZH] 而是說這個人以環境的適配之下
[EN*]  We want to make a difference in the environment.
[EN*]  Okay, in the interest of time,
[EN*]  I will skip the next slide.
[EN*]  Now, I refer to reciprocal adaptation, big word, but this brings us back to this reciprocal
[EN*]  adaptation issue.
[EN*]  Sometimes a person may benefit from change, communication strategies, self-regulation,
[EN]  coping strategies, self-advocacy or clinical treatment when useful, but sometimes the ecology
[EN]  should change. Sensory demand, unclear expectations, unpredictable routines, rigid participation
[EN]  requirements, or communication practices. So treatment and accommodation can work together.
[EN]  The question is not that who should change the person environment. The better question that
[EN]  we need to ask here is what combination of changes supports this person's life?
[ZH] 接下來我們再來談回雙向改變
[ZH] 有的時候一個人可以從改變中破譯
[ZH] 比如說溝通的策略,還有自我調節
[ZH] 但是有的時候應該環境也可以做出一些調整和改變
[ZH] 比如說就是我們可以去調整這個人的感官需求
[ZH] 我們可以去調整對他的期望
[ZH] 還有去靈活調整參與的方式、溝通方式等等
[ZH] 所以治療跟適應其實是可以共存共存的
[ZH] 所以這個問題並不是誰應該要做出改變
[ZH] 是環境要改變還是這個當事人要去改變
[ZH] 比較好的問法應該是
[ZH] 就是不同的改變他們一起發生了
[ZH] 可以怎麼樣好好支援這個人的人生?
[EN]  Now, let me just bring the discussion directly back to Taiwan.
[EN]  And then finish with a larger question,
[EN]  what kind of community outcomes we are ultimately trying to create?
[EN]  Now, I'll produce this slide with considerable humility,
[EN]  because you know Taiwan's system much better than I do.
[EN]  Taiwan already has important strengths,
[EN]  developmental screening and assessment,
[EN]  national health care infrastructure,
[EN]  special education provisions,
[EN]  and early intervention services.
[EN]  But from a community psychology perspective,
[EN]  another question emerges.
[EN]  What happens beyond early intervention?
[EN]  What happens in adolescents?
[EN]  Can support follow the person
[EN]  across different school settings?
[EN]  What happens in adulthood and employment?
[EN]  are accommodation and meaningful participation available
[EN]  and beyond services altogether,
[EN]  can people develop friendships, relationships,
[EN]  belonging and meaningful roles in ordinary community life.
[EN]  The studies by Westby and colleagues
[EN]  and by Chen and colleagues also remind us
[EN]  that access and service conditions can vary
[EN]  by setting and local ecology.
[EN]  So my point here, the slide, is that services are not that they are unimportant, quite the opposite.
[ZH] 好服務是重要的,但服務並不保證你依照。
[ZH] 還有青少年階段的時候
[ZH] 這些支援資源可不可以跨場域
[ZH] 跨體系持續幫助他們銜接還有陪伴
[ZH] 以及等到他們成年以後
[ZH] 職場還有社會是否具備合理的環境調整
[ZH] 以及讓他們有實質的參與工作機會
[ZH] 以及在社群和生活當中
[ZH] 神經動向性的青年
[ZH] 可不可以在社群中建立真實的人際關係
[ZH] 獲得歸屬感
[EN*]  we can think about some of the dimensions of community life can i enter here
[EN]  can i function here without unnecessary barriers can i take part meaningfully am i
[EN]  recognized as a valued member can i matter here now this should not necessarily be understood as
[EN]  rigid stages someone can have access without participation someone can participate without
[EN]  the feeling that they belong, and contribution does not mean economic productivity, it can mean that the person's presence, relationships, perspectives, care, or participation has value within shared community life, so the goal here is not simply inclusion by physical presence, but it is community membership.
[ZH] 而,貢獻並不是經濟的充足,而是人的身份,關係,觀眾,關係,關係,關係,關係,關係,關係,關係,關係,關係,關係。
[ZH] 所以,這個目的目的,不是單純的充足,而是社會的充足。
[ZH] 那所以就是社群心理學
[ZH] 其實它有更多樣的這個面向去討論
[ZH] 比如說就是我們可以在這裡做我自己嗎
[ZH] 我可以好好的參與嗎
[ZH] 我屬於這裡嗎
[ZH] 我可以發揮我的作用嗎
[ZH] 發揮我的價值嗎
[ZH] 那所以這些並不是用一個很僵化的階段去理解的
[ZH] 就是有些人呢可以獲得參與感
[ZH] 那有些人呢是需要有歸屬感
[ZH] 所以這些貢獻並不表示說
[ZH] 是否對社會做出貢獻並不表示說
[ZH] 一定是可以賺錢
[ZH] 或是在經濟上面有做出生產力
[ZH] 這意味的是這個人他有沒有價值感
[ZH] 存在感好好的發展出他人的關係
[ZH] 他的觀點是否被重視
[ZH] 他能不能得到很好的關懷
[ZH] 那所以我們的目標就並不只是在生理或是物理上面接納一個人,而是要讓他真正成為一個社群的成員,讓他有心理上面的歸屬感。
[EN]  Now, let me end with the only phrase, with the rules of laws.
[EN]  There's no home, there's no place like home.
[EN]  Home, in this sense, is more than a place where we are allowed to enter.
[EN]  It is a place where we can participate, where we are known, where we belong, where we matter.
[EN]  And for many years, for many years, autism intervention has understandably asked,
[EN]  How can we help autistic people become better prepared for school, work, relationship, and community life?
[EN]  We should continue asking that question.
[EN]  But I would like us to place a second question right beside it.
[EN]  That is, how can schools, workplaces, clinics, families, and communities become better prepared for autistic people?
[EN]  The future of autism support, I believe, depends on both.
[EN]  not treatment without dignity, not acceptance without needed support,
[EN]  not individual education without environmental responsibility,
[EN]  but an approach in which people can receive the support they need and at the same time participate, belong, and matter.
[EN]  So perhaps the final question that you and I have to ask is very simple.
[ZH] 我最後想用綠眼仙中的明言作解,沒有地方比得上家,
[ZH] 家在這個層面來說,並不是形式上的家庭,
[ZH] 而是一個我們可以讓名詞接納還有進入的地方
[ZH] 讓每個人有參與感的地方
[ZH] 讓我們覺得有歸屬感和發揮價值的地方
[ZH] 所以我們常常會想要介入自閉症患者的方式是
[ZH] 我們要怎麼樣幫助自閉症患者
[ZH] 可以更好準備面對學校工作還有關係還有社群與生活
[ZH] 那現在我覺得我們應該也要問說
[ZH] 我們學校、工作場域還有診所、家庭、社群
[ZH] 可以怎麼樣來調整來更好準備為這些致病療症患者服務
[ZH] 所以這個很重要的就是所有的治療都應該要讓人有尊嚴感
[EN*]  And everyone needs to be trusted.
[EN*]  So, the final question is very simple.
[EN*]  I can do it here, I can participate in it, I can have a value in it, I can have a value in it.
[EN*]  So, ladies and gentlemen, thank you very much for listening.
[EN*]  Thank you very much for listening.
[EN*]  What is community perspective between psychology?